We have a voicemail number. That number is
two one nine to David P. here's a voicemail
with an interesting little prediction about
what will happen to this show if Donald Trump
loses. I've talked before about, listen, there's
no question. I think Trump is terrible for
the country in the world, but our show is
bigger today. Thanks to Trump being the president
than Hillary. Had Hillary been the president,
I don't believe independent media. This is
not just my show, would have seen nearly the
growth that we've seen since November of 2016
that's a reality. I still want the guy to
lose because he's terrible for the country.
Here's a different type of prediction about
what Trump's loss would lead to for the David
Pakman show.
Hello, David. This is different California
and I just want to tell you what exactly is
going to happen. The house will vote to impeach.
The Senate will not be able to get a, so the
president will not get thrown out because
of the impeachment. We're going to have to
put them out then if we're lucky enough to
vote him out, I don't think you're going to
add your radio show anymore because as soon
as they vote him out, I think he might get
hired by Fox news. Wow. To replace Shepard
Smith. That's the end of the David Pakman
show.
Yeah. Um, I don't see that happening at any
time. I would be, I can't even imagine. I
was going to say I would be last on the list
to replace Shep Smith on Fox news. I don't
even think I'm on any list that exists for
doing anything on Fox news. Particularly.
Remember the last time I was supposed to be
on Fox news, I took a Lyft over to the, the
satellite studio. Nobody was there. I called
and was told, Oh, nobody told you that Fox
canceled this several hours ago. No, nobody
told me. Um, and uh, that's the last I ever
heard from them and they've not invited me
back on since. And it was quite a, quite a
fiasco. So in any case, um, no I don't. Uh,
I don't see any plan for that. I don't see
any path to that whatsoever. We have a great
bonus show planned for you today.
If you're satisfied with what you've seen
from us today so far, then forget about the
bonus show. If you want more today, instead
of waiting until tomorrow, become a member
or a patron@patriondotcomslashdavidpakmanshoworjoinpacman.com
because on the bonus show we will talking
about, uh, Barack Obama said something very
interesting. Barack Obama said, Democrats
don't always need to be politically woke and
tweeting stuff on Twitter is not really activism.
Very interesting comments. We will also talk
about a girlfriend charged in the death of
a Boston college student after telling him
hundreds of time to kill himself according
to prosecutors. A very disturbing but legally
interesting case. And we will talk about the
California fires warnings for Los Angeles
or progressing North, a former T V director
of the David Pakman show, Naton Pacman. Oh,
having [inaudible]
to work from home as a result of these fires.
He lives in LA. Can you imagine all of those
stories and more on the bonus show? I'll see
you then. The David Pakman show@davidpakman.com
[inaudible].